can you hear me yeah i can hear you you
hear me okay yeah
okay all right we can get started now
i'm recording the podcast if you need to
pause it or whatever just let me know
okay
that might happen if someone could knock
on my door i think at this hour that's
unlikely but yeah okay stop at that
point we'll handle them we'll send some
of your russian friends to deal with
that that's right
okay
all right so we'll begin now well
welcome everybody to the first episode
of into the impossible
from the arthur c clarke center for
human imagination at the university of
california san diego
remind you that into the imaginati into
the impossible rather is a unique
podcast that really
aims to explore the boundaries of human
imagination and curiosity in every
endeavor from the arts to the sciences
to technology and beyond
and we've done episodes with numerous
luminaries intellectuals
from nobel prize winning physicist to
pulitzer prize-winning poets to
astronauts uh to
everyday uh thinkers uh
and intellectuals around the world so
it's a great honor and pleasure today to
start off uh the new year 2019 with a
podcast with an episode of one of my
scientific heroes and mentors professor
paul steinhardt who is the einstein
profession professor of natural sciences
at princeton university he's also the
author of
of two books for popular science
audiences and today we're going to be
talking about his latest book which is
called the second kind of impossible
which is due to come out tomorrow
january 8th so this is book launch eve a
very you know nervous time in any
author's life
quite similar to uh waiting the birth of
a child or christmas morning
which for paul was the birth of himself
and also christmas day and paul's
birthday is on christmas day shared with
a famous uh a person who achieved a
great deal of fame uh throughout
humanity which is of course isaac newton
and that that is one of the many
similarities between paul and the great
physicist
today we're going to be talking about
his new book we did record an episode
with paul almost exactly two years ago
on into the impossible and that was
about his previous book which is called
endless universe which he co-wrote with
professor neil turock at the perimeter
institution and that's sort of about a
very interesting idea for cosmological
origins and the pursuit of scientific
knowledge very much at the heart of what
i do as a professional experimental
cosmologist looking for signals from the
very early universe that book is very
influential in my career and many of my
colleagues
and this one i have to say is going to
be influential uh to a whole host of
people ranging from
my children to many children around the
world uh and and and it's already i
should point out i should give you a
congratulations already number one on
amazon uh in the
mineralogy category so that's that's a
first for me
you're truly a rock star now paul
all puns intended so uh first since the
book i have not yet read the book i've
only read the sample chapter i'm
awaiting my copy to be
delivered physically and wirelessly
later on tonight
but i wanted to
have you explain a little bit of the
overall theme of the book and how it
came to be and what prompted you to
write it and not giving it away i always
hate when you get do an interview with a
podcast and they say tell me you know
everything about the book that a reader
could possibly learn without having to
buy the audiobook or the physical book
which no author wants to hear so
i want you to uh to wet our appetites
for this phenomenal book which uh which
we're eagerly anticipating receiving
very soon
well i'll do my best so thanks for
having me brian
um yeah so the book is a very unusual
science story that is
at one level it's a story about
a new form of matter that was once
believed to be impossible for actually
for hundreds of years we thought it was
impossible for atoms and molecules to
form this form of matter that we today
call a quasi crystal
begins with the origin of that idea
which i was involved in back in the
1980s
and then it turns uh
to the story of
where we might find these quasi crystals
they were first found in the laboratory
so around the same time that we were
speculating about this hypothetical
possibility of a new form of matter
and then the question arose
in my mind whether or not nature may
have made this form of material before
humans did
before we made them in the laboratory
so
we you know back in the 1980s we had a
sort of mathematical or hypothetical
idea
a group working a few hundred miles to
the south of us
accidentally discovered such a material
in the laboratory that's how the subject
was born
just by a coincidence
and then uh but then the question arose
maybe nature made them before us and if
so where would we look for them and
that's kind of a where do you start to
look for a new form of matter that you
haven't seen before and by the way why
haven't you seen that form of matter
before if it's possible if we can make
it in the laboratory how is that we
haven't seen it in nature already
and
so that's that was a quest that began
around 1998
it's formal
as a formal quest
and it's been
continuing for the last 20 years
and it's a story which is
you know part science story part
detective story
part mystery
it involves
kgb agents and smugglers and
and
and all kinds of other strange aspects
missing persons and
strange romanians and all kinds of other
aspects you don't normally see in a
science story even bears
come into the story so it has a little
bit of everything uh and at the bottom
of it was a search as to whether or not
these natural quasi crystals whether the
quasi crystals this new form of matter
really has can be found in nature or not
and uh the story then goes on to tell
how
uh we discovered uh there were it was
found in nature and where we found it
and what's so interesting to me is yes
you've um
you've you've been called many things in
your career and i think one of the most
flattering and sort of the one i'm most
envious about is indiana steinhardt and
that is uh can you give a little bit of
a insight as to why you'd receive such a
delightful moniker
well uh so the part of the story i
didn't tell you is where we had to
actually find this uh this strange new
mineral and
the answer after a long novel-esque
story of tracing down a grain that was
found in a museum basement in florence
italy
to figuring out where it came from
eventually took us to a very remote
uninhabited region of
the kamchatka peninsula
the not the part that we're familiar out
with that sticks out the sea of akusk
that is
today even tourists can go there but a
part which
not even russians can normally visit the
northern part of it of the kumchaka
peninsula just across the bering strait
from alaska a part that's called
chukotka
in the mountains of
chukotka far from any inhabited region
it turns out in a small stream there
that turned out to be the place where we
were able to find new grains of this
strange material
and we hadn't collected through our
detective story a number of hints that
it might be there but the only way we
could prove it was there was to actually
actually put together a team of
geologists
uh who would join with me and go out
into the middle of nowhere fly fly to
the far eastern russia uh the farthest
most eastern part northernmost part of
russia beyond siberia to the kanchatka
peninsula and travel by
by a strange form of transportation to
the mountains and we spent
about a dozen days there looking for
grains of this new material collecting
lots of samples and fortunately we came
back and actually found these grains and
and from those were able to learn
where they came from originally
and one of the things i remember you
you've given a couple of just extremely
fascinating talks about this um in the
last you know almost two decades or more
than two decades since you started this
mystery
adventure story um in your career and
one of them that really spoke out and is
really i'm eagerly anticipating reading
as you know i i'm a student of sort of
scientific heredity and and how
a scientist becomes a scientist and and
more than just their natural raw
intellectual horsepower but that you
know at least maybe your russian you
know colleagues if they're free from you
know kgb influence can tell that the
word scientist and when translated in
russian means someone who is taught
and it literally you know reflects the
process by which in science i believe
that science is actually communicated
from human to human not from you know
wikipedia page to wikipedia page and the
book opens at least from the sample
chapter that i had the opportunity to
read with a description of one of your
great scientific mentors which is
richard feynman one of the greatest
physicists you may be in history and
certainly of the 20th century and that
he was one of your mentors and advisors
as an undergraduate and obviously
maintain close relation with him
um and so i want to ask you about that
and then i want to connect it to
another character who recalls central to
this story which is your graduate
student though levine
and and what what
later kind of influence he had in the
field of of this of this magical new
form of matter which is really as you
say thought to be impossible so uh
before we enter that can you explain
what does it mean where did this title
come from our listeners may be uh
interested why is it the second kind of
impossible what does that mean
yeah so the title refers to the idea
that uh and when you're trying to look
to make a new discovery in science
i i've for to me
what i always pay attention to is
whenever someone tells you that
something is impossible
so you know sometimes when a scientist
says something is impossible there are
really solid reasons why it is
impossible it's absolutely
violating something that we know to be
true
that we can prove is true and
there's no loopholes around it
so um
an example of that is if i were to give
you a bunch of let's say squares and
asked you to tile your floor with
squares you know you could do it and
fill the floor without any gaps but if i
gave you a bunch of perfect pentagons
regular pentagons that's mathematically
impossible you cannot fill the four with
pentagons without
having spaces between them
on the other hand sometimes when
scientists say something is impossible
they're saying it's impossible
based on some assumptions that they're
making that maybe they're not even aware
of they're so common and so
uh so apparently true that they just
take it for granted and then they reach
a conclusion from that
so for example one of the things that
we've known in science for centuries is
that atoms and molecules
like to come together just like tiles
and so if you as to say crystals for
example are
form building blocks
similar to tiles which just join
together you know edge to edge to fill a
solid and make the crystal and we know
that accounts for many of the properties
of crystals including the way they facet
and form those nice beautiful facets
that we're all familiar with and that we
find attractive
and
it also affects a lot of their
electronic and physical properties and
so for a long time we believed just like
we can put squares together to make
tiles we can put atoms and molecules
together to make crystals but there are
certain shapes which are absolutely
forbidden for example you cannot have
any form of matter which has facets
which have perfect pentagon shapes
for basically the same reasons you
cannot tile a floor with perfect
pentagons and that was an absolute
rigorous law of matter
that
everyone learned when who studied matter
for the last several hundred years
now the question is
is that really impossible of the sort
that is absolutely rigorously true or
have you made some assumption
and it turns out you have made some
assumption in the second kind of
impossible
you've made an assumption that matter
only can form a single kind of building
block just like a single pentagon or a
single square
another logical possibility once you
think about it is that suppose matter
forms let's say two different kinds of
building blocks two different shapes and
they don't repeat edge to edge you know
one after the other but they repre in a
complicated sequence with sort of two
different frequencies at two different
sets of intervals
it turns out you can then make something
new that people hadn't considered before
called a quasi crystal
a new form of material and so while it
was thought to be impossible to have any
material with fivefold facets that turns
out to be the second kind of impossible
the kind of impossible that was based on
an assumption that turns out not to be
true matter doesn't have to form that
way
and it can form therefore all kinds of
new shapes that we thought were
mathematically forbidden
and it's not just one shape not just i'm
just focusing on the pentagons because
those were the first examples found
but before the discovery of quasi
crystals there was really only
a small number of different possible
patterns that we thought matter could
make we discovered that we were missing
an infinite number of possibilities and
we've only discovered a few
new possibilities so far but we know
that they're beginning at the beginning
of
an unbounded set of new new shapes and
possibilities
so they are the example of the second
kind of a possible something that you
thought was impossible but
actually
you find the light when you look at your
assumptions and you find the loophole
you can just discover something
dramatically new
so someone said the second kind is
really a pret reflects a prejudice of
the one who's uh interpreting or
claiming the impossibility whereas the
first kind might be imposed by nature or
you know herself in a certain sense that
you really can't
accuse of being prejudiced except that
it displays certain types of phenomena
is there a third type of impossible that
you're aware of is that ai
well maybe some future book will be
about that but i don't know of one at
the moment at least for my thinking is
he ordinary human scientist thinking i'm
usually trying to decide when someone i
hear the word impossible my ears pick up
and i'm really trying to always imagine
you know what has the person assumed to
reach that conclusion
and
can i am just imagine
there's something
different something different that some
something that might be altered about
that assumption and if so why that would
be interesting so almost all the time
i'm listening to a talk about any
anything in science any topic in science
i'm kind of listening with two ears i'm
listening on the one hand for what the
person's saying but i'm always asking
myself that question
what have they assumed and could it be
wrong and it and then could that lead to
something interesting
yeah in fact the name of our of our
podcast into the impossible really
traces from an arthur c clark quote
which uh says something to the effect
that the only way to find out what's
possible is to venture a little bit into
the impossible which really belies you
know as you're saying this is the second
the second form of impossibility i think
people really you know artificially
constrict themselves by by imposing
certain types of biases etc i mean some
are basically rules of thumb that for
some reason get elevated as you point
out you know even the great richard
feynman uh who i want to get back to now
you know i had when you first presented
this which must have been just the most
you know kind of surreal experience to
be back in the presence of your mentor
your you know
and but as a peer and as a as as a
scientist with
with you know abilities equal to and you
know in some ways to what feynman was
capable of and then to have him
seemingly crushingly you know critique
your
uh result in in in the audience you know
afterwards you know as impossible right
and and
what how did you how were you able to
sort of persevere you know through that
was it just the strength of conviction
that what you had claimed because at
that time there were no natural or
artificial you know kind of examples
right of what you were conjecturing at
least in terms of you had shown that
there are mathematical
possibilities for it how do you handle
such you know critique i mean luckily he
was you know have sort of an evocular
you know uh feeling for you but you know
how was that i mean a lot of people were
would would have gone into a vast amount
of psychotherapy if feynman told them
what they were saying was stupid and
impossible
how did you handle that well yeah
fortunately it was not my first
experience with feynman or i think i
would have you know just shrunk under
the desk or something like that
so this was a few years after i had been
a student at caltech and and had a
number of interactions close
interactions with dick feynman
among them
well first of all he is the person that
really brought me into physics when i
went to cal tech as an undergraduate
i didn't really know much about physics
at all for some reason that was just a
missing part of my science education
over a week part of my science education
within a few weeks i i encountered
feynman and finding lectures on physics
and i was converted
i didn't know exactly what i wanted to
do in in science or in physics i should
say uh but i tried to watch closely
feynman who was my hero quickly became
my hero to see you know what
what he what which way he would point
uh appoint me
um and one of the things i did when i
was a junior is with my roommate we went
to visit finding we asked him if he'd be
willing to
uh give a course that came to be
physics x
turns out he had done something like
this a number of years ago a slightly
different format but would he come and
give this course physicsx in which you'd
come each week it's an unofficial course
wasn't on the registrar's you know list
and you get and you just come and talk
about whatever you wanted to talk about
whatever physical phenomena you want to
talk about and so that's what happened
every week he would come and he'd you'd
come and ask him a question about
something it had to be something about
something you you observed in nature or
you know knew about existing in nature
and he would do his best to tackle it
and
what i learned from that was what i
expected to learn from that interaction
was
that
he would be pointing heavily to the work
he himself had done in elementary
particle physics
but in fact we hardly discussed particle
physics at all the subjects
roomed all over the map and every
subject was fascinating
so
what i learned from that is that physics
um the opportunity for physics
discoveries can be found everywhere in
in everything and everything is
interesting everything was interesting
to find so everything was interesting to
us and he could just you could describe
everything in such a way that uh he
could tackle anything such a way that
was fascinating captivating
and
that was an important influence on me
because in my own research you know i
kind of followed a path that began with
particle physics
to begin with but then it soon began
wandering to other areas such as the
topic we're talking about the topic of
this book
but in another interaction with him i
was doing some research with him on
various topics and
and you know feynman was known for
giving people a really hard time in
lectures and calling them foolish and
stupid and things like that
and so you know i had some of that i'd
come to his office and present an idea
and he explained to me an idea whether
that would be it was foolish or stupid
but you know to me it always
it was never insulting it was done in a
certain
you know
certain way of enthusiasm and it was
consistent but what really convinced me
that it was
you know i should take it in stride was
there was one time when you know he
accused me of something getting
something stupid and wrong
and
it involved involved a super ball and
the way you can so ball can spin and
bounce and fortunately i had a super
ball with me and i
demonstrated to him um that in fact uh
i wasn't sure how i was going to work
out we tried the experiment that he was
proposing and sure enough it turned out
that what i had predicted in my
equations was correct and he turned
around and said ah stupid referring to
himself and then i realized he would use
that term for anybody who got something
wrong
more to jolt them into paying attention
something interesting was going on here
you ought to pay attention and not
simply overlook it can something be
learned here
so okay so
years later
i'm giving um this talk that you're
describing in this lecture on one of
these early lectures on quasi crystals
and um fein was in the audience and
listening very intently and i was
expecting him to interrupt he didn't
interrupt at any time during the lecture
itself he waited till
it was over
um
and
he came up and said
well this is impossible you know uh
people were leaving the room but it
echoed throughout the room that you know
it was clear that you know feynman was
objecting to this idea that there could
be this new form of matter even though i
had done my best to present you know
lots of evidence of it including even in
demonstration of it
but i could tell from his smile that it
was it was the impossible like you know
like he would call me stupid or
something impossible in the past he was
really challenging me to to prove my
point
and and what he then asked me to do was
i had done a demonstration in front of
the uh lecture to show what happens when
you shine
um well it'd be like if you showed
electrons to such a hypothetical
material in this case i was using a
laser and a slide which had the same
pattern as the arrangement of atoms
would have in the material
and what i had shown is that it produced
a pattern that was supposed to be
impossible according to all the standard
textbooks on solids and that was the
point of the lecture that there are
these new possibilities that were had
been considered impossible they were now
impossible so having declared the whole
idea impossible he then walked up to me
and said i want to see that
demonstration again
so
we turned off the lights we turned back
on the laser we did the demonstration
again he looked back and forth between
what was on the wall and the laser he
picked up the slide he looked at the
slide he put it back in
and
yeah he said you just smile give a huge
smile
that really is impossible and that was
you know and then you know slowly walked
out of the room with a big smile on his
face and uh so i felt it was my chance
to sort of return a favor that he had
given me and giving me so many thrills
in physics it was my chance to return a
thrill to him and i think he appreciated
the present
yeah i mean that kind of goes along with
my you know never told you this but my
impression of you is you're sort of a
happy warrior you know sort of of of
science where you're you really just are
mischievous and playful and you don't do
stuff for personal gain although as
we'll hopefully get to there are things
you know that could lead to potential
financial or or technological
improvements based on your predictions
your theory or experimental findings
and you know i think that's important to
think about but but you seem to do
things for as feynman would say you know
the pleasure of finding things out
rather than some implication or
application and i wonder you know when
you were supervising your own student i
mean you're very unlike fine men in
terms of i think you know
he was very rough around the edges and
he might have been had a warm heart i
never knew him but uh but you know he
might have had her but it would be hard
to discern that from the outside he was
very
shrouded in sort of a mythology that he
helped to cultivate
and is you know partially responsible
for why his books and books about him
and multiple biographies and
autobiographies have been written about
him but when you were working with your
student was there ever a time this is
dove
that i'm speaking about was there any
time ever a time when you actually
worried about his career like what he ha
it's one thing for you you know you're
this esteemed scientist even by that
point but what about him uh
what kind of obligations or what kind of
risks are appropriate to
assign to your students or your men the
people that you mentor you know on your
behalf you're not always going to be
there to fight their battles and so how
did you juggle that uh because it could
be risky right
um you need to do high risk science how
to do the higher risk science maverick
kind of you know
i think science is only worthwhile if
you think you're taking some risk
especially as a theoretical physicist
well i think both as a theoretical
physicist and an experimental physicist
you're taking risks you're taking
different kinds of risks
as a theoretical physicist you're taking
a risk of your ideas you're putting in
an idea that might make you look stupid
it might be wrong
stupidly wrong it might just be
something inconsistent with it or it
might be
logically possible but nature just
didn't choose that course
on the other hand there's that thrill
uh if you are lucky enough to come up
with an idea even a tiny idea you know
that you then discover is
actually the way nature works
i just find that to be just
that's that's what that really that's
the that's the moment that really draws
me to science what i what i really love
most is that brief moment even for a
small idea
where you feel you realize you
discovered something that no one knew
before and you're actually the only
person on the planet that knows it
probably
and maybe in a bit later you're going to
share that idea but i actually don't
relish sharing that idea immediately i
like to just enjoy that moment for a bit
and think about it and before i release
you know before before i
sort of release the idea into the into
the world and uh that's worth everything
to me in science and so i try to
by example try to bring that to my to my
students
to first of all question
you know the things that we assume to be
true see if you can find some
some new way of thinking about it that
uh that can lead to a new idea
learn how to become disciplined in terms
of the use of mathematics and logic to
to
to to work out your idea and then to be
very serious about
experiment an observation
uh take it seriously if the observations
or experiments go against you try to
resist patching and and doing and fixing
an idea and adding you know bells and
whistles to it if nature is not agreeing
with it respect nature is the arbiter
i try to communicate all those ideas
depending upon where we are at any given
stage of a problem or a question that
we're asking
yeah i find it you know interesting i
was talking on a podcast i was doing
with someone else today about how you
know the difference between he asked me
what's the difference between being a
theorist like yourself and an
experimentalist such as myself you know
is it like being a democrat and a
republican well not really i mean we
both study polarization but it's a
different kind of polarization and
political polarization it's the good
kind of polarization
but we came to the conclusion it's more
like you know kind of the offense and
the defense of a football team you know
where they both have a common goal
they're very different tools and
techniques they're not competing with
each other but you know they both have a
little bit of a swagger and they both
have a little bit of a chip on their
shoulder something to prove um i don't
know which of the two of us would be you
know kind of the the offense versus the
defense i i view the the kind of
experimentalists though if i interpret
what you're saying is sort of the
gatekeepers you know the ones who are
going to
be work on behalf of nate mother nature
as arbiter you know kind of present the
evidence of course we make our
fair share of mistakes too and we are
subject to exactly the same kinds of
biases but there is sort of the sense
you know to use nicholas uh and nassim
nicholas telleb's phrase and also one
that jim simons likes to use a lot of
skin in the game you know that you you
can create a lot of theories
as a theorist and you know if nobody you
know if you get one right so to speak
whatever that means and you'll get
enough attention that could make your
whole career right or if it becomes so
influential that even if it's not proven
or more
aptly falsified you may enjoy a very
long and productive career um on the
other hand if you keep having
experiments that keep failing and not
producing results you're not going to
have a very long career
and so there are some elements of that
and you can't just have a strong offense
you can't just have a strong defense
they kind of have to work together but
it seems to me that experimentalists
might have more need to think about the
skin in the game as as you're talking
about that there's this investment of
course that comes with the challenge
that we may be
you know kind of influenced to to
interpret our results in a way most
favorable to a prevailing you know field
or theory and i wonder you know in your
career which you know you're still young
but you've you've
seen you know you bridge the gap from
the you know the greatest physicists of
the of the 20th century and now into the
21st century that that you're helping to
lead at the vanguard i mean what you see
is a difference between the way that
theoretical physics works there's a book
now called lost in math by a physicist
named sabine haasenfelder in germany it
was very critical of modern theoretical
physics of course as she gives a real
short shrift to experiment but she which
i think is blossomed in astronomy and
cosmology
experiments in particular of course i'm
biased but but she really says there
haven't been any new you know
theoretical developments in physics
since the mid 70s i wonder
hey do you agree with that and b do you
think that's a symptom of of something
if you do agree with it or or is there
something else going on in the culture
that uh that we need to be aware of
that's a good question uh
i i think they're um
i think that the um
the last few decades has been um
unusual in the course of theoretical
physics i think you know when i when i
was coming into the field up until the
time i was coming into the field i think
there was very close interaction between
theory and experiment both in the areas
of fundamental physics and there was
soon to be in in cosmology
uh
say particle physics fundamental physics
and cosmology and um
i think that the
the
beginning in the 1980s there were you
know two prevalent ideas that began to
take over
many people's thinking one of which was
uh we call super string theory or string
theory
as a possible description of the
fundamental forces and
constituents of nature and the other in
cosmology this idea of inflationary
cosmology the idea that we can explain
why the universe is the way it is
because
um the universe after the big bang
underwent a period of ex rapid
stretching or accelerated expansion that
smoothed it out and um these ideas
propagated in a way which
didn't um and on the string theory side
had very little connection with
observation because string theory more
or less involves energy scales
that are beyond our
direct testing but to the degree to
which it had some implications
uh some strong suggestions of what we
should see
what we learned over the last
decade since then is that essentially
all those suggestions have not worked
out so string theory suggested that we
should have a whole new set of particles
called supersymmetric partners
that were supposed to be observed at the
large hadron collider at cern we don't
see those
i was it's suggested that dark matter is
probably a particular kind species of
particle called a wimp a weakly
interacting massive particle we don't
see that
it
is an idea which is hard to accommodate
with the idea that we re there's the
observation that we've discovered since
the uh
since the
introduction of string theory the
discovery of the universe is
undergoing a period of accelerated
expansion that seems hard to
accommodate in string theory
the idea of inflation seems hard to
accommodate in string theory um
so
and yet the idea is still prevalent
today it's prevalent because you know
several generations of young theorists
have been told from the start that you
know this is the only idea we have for
making a
unified theory of quantum physics and
gravity and the other interactions and
perhaps it's so but when you have a
track record like that you would expect
no under healthy conditions there should
be other ideas out there and there
should be a healthy opposition that says
well here's some
competing ideas and i think that one of
the things that's happened in string
theory and i'll talk again about
cosmology in a moment
is that there's also a strong there's a
new element in the game which is a very
strong social network uh
it's related to the internet and it's
related to
the way the field has self-organized
itself it has a very strong
socio-political component to it as well
as a scientific component that strongly
encourages students to
you know to to take
this idea and assume it
as an essential ingredient from the
start so
i understand that they're enthusiasts
but it disturbs me when i hear a young
person begin with a statement like well
we all know string theory is the correct
description of the universe
based on what why aren't you questioning
that assumption it goes back to the
second kind of impossible idea
if that is what you're being told you
should be challenging you're
challenging
yourself to ask is that really true what
really makes me believe it's true is it
because authorities are telling me that
uh because or or can i think of any
other way around it it just surprises me
that there isn't more competition
there's a similar story in cosmology the
story is a little bit different
their
inflation began the idea of inflationary
inflationary universe idea began as a
rather simple and compelling idea
um
in fact that's it was the study of
inflation that brought me into cosmology
in the first place um but what we
discovered over the years is two
interesting things uh number one that
the early ideas
that we thought inflation would
there are any ideas of inflationary
cosmology and what it would predict
those predictions turned out to be
verified
by observations so far with one notable
exception
on the other hand
we learned that the theory doesn't work
the way we thought it did it doesn't
make those predictions at all
uh as you know we had not properly
understood
how the theory would work how what the
role of quantum physics would be when
combined with gravity when you have
inflation involved and so at the same
time
the justification for those predictions
has disappeared we really need a new
idea
and
again you know what's happened in the
field is that because our early
misconception of the inflationary theory
led to
so-called predictions
or
what we thought were predictions that
turned out to be true
many people just take for granted the
theory must somehow be right even if our
understanding of the theory today
doesn't correspond to our early
understanding of it as to say the
predictions are no longer
can no longer be justified and it's
coming from the theory
and again there's just too few people
who are challenging the idea that we
have to have a big bang or that we have
to have inflation
even though those ideas are not really
explaining the data that you and other
colleagues of yours the experimentalists
and observers are finding
in fact one of the things that inflation
would generally predict is that you
should have had
a spectrum of
gravitational waves that should have
been
of cosmic wavelengths cosmic scales and
they should have been strong enough to
be observed today
and so far we're not seeing them and
that's you know even observationally a
direct challenge to the theory
and
nevertheless what you see is that what
most people are doing including most
young people is they're just trying to
add bells and whistles to the theory
that will help it to evade the current
observational constraints or the next
round of observational constraints
rather than
ask the obvious question which is
uh
is it possible that
the ideas in which we've been assuming
all along are wrong and if so
can we use the observations we have to
come up with a new and better idea
so it's been a strange period where uh
strong social networks and uh you know
supporting these different ideas and the
way in fact supporting the two of them
together oftentimes you know has helped
support ideas when i there certainly has
to be opportunity for new ideas given
what we've learned
yeah it's interesting that's especially
challenging when i tried to convince you
to get a twitter account recently
and was met with strong opposition to
certain social networks uh but see that
as it may i i think i think you'll do
quite well without such a
contrivance um i think it's interesting
just hearing you talk and just really
thinking about it for the first time
with your first book which is which is
really showing the impossibility of
something that everybody thought was
mandatory to now going to showing the
possibility of everything something
people thought was forbidden uh it seems
it seems
you know almost like a theme that uh one
can pursue sort of and should pursue for
you know the the the to the profit of
the pursuer perhaps you know the
contrarian point of view it seems that
is
uh you know not being contrarian for the
contrarian's sake but i think that seems
to be a core message of your work in in
this book that that people you know
taking sometimes taking the oppositional
viewpoint uh even and having confidence
which i think you can only get
confidence based on you know prior uh
prior successes i don't think you know
someone should come in and just be
incredibly confident about his or her
abilities um but i think that that is
you've proven that to be quite uh
a fruitful avenue i want to finish the
the discussion today getting back to the
to the book the new book the second kind
of impossible which is uh professor paul
steinhardt's new book
the extraordinary quest for a new form
of matter uh which i think is such a
sweeping
uh concept and you know i saw i have the
benefit of having not read the book but
seen the seen the movie seen the uh the
the the colloquium about it and just
being riveted as everybody was and you
know this really the quest takes us on a
journey from you know the ancient greeks
and their their sort of um obsession
with mathematical beauty and purity
which would sometimes lead to um actual
you know fundamental results i mean they
would show the the pythagorean solids
and it's not like we'd added new you
know pythagorean solids that they could
have known about that they didn't
discover that obviously has direct
applicability to the crystallographic
structures that you describe in the book
but i think the greeks in contra
distinction to the romans and the the
roman school was you know the the greeks
couldn't get enough theory and pure
abstraction and that the romans couldn't
have any of it you know they want to
build aqueducts and actually do things
that was practical and useful to to
humanity and to their subjects uh but
and so you did that in your in your book
not not only literally going you know
working with italian
archaeology geminologist and so forth
but uh but really looking into
this finding you know kind of the the
natural and the artificial occurrence of
these of these objects these quasi
crystals which really to impress upon
the
listener
of the podcast is truly as the book
subtitles as a new form of matter
which is wholly unexpected and and
delightful and and and you have many
illustrations in the book which make it
um very visually compelling and
beautiful even i think
uh one one of the things that always you
know speaks to me as an experimentalist
someone who's dealing you know skin in
the game and trying to build stuff that
actually works and returns results in a
on a 10-year track life you know life
cycle the the thing for me is you know
what to what extent is does our research
as physicists have to be practical and
it turns out that your these results and
maybe you can briefly explain
the results that that may have
commercial
applicability viability and then whether
or not you know is that important i
personally think it is but um what are
your thoughts on that we've never
discussed that really
okay well first of all let me make the
just to elaborate a bit on what you're
referring to
so
um
as i mentioned earlier if you have
matter in which the atoms and molecules
or structures have a new novel kind of
arrangement that's mathematically
different
uh in a fundamental way we know that
those same mathematical properties have
physical implications it means this can
have new physical properties so one of
the things that you know we showed about
quasi crystals
many years ago it's generically going to
be stronger and
less plastically deformable than
ordinary crystals are
and that gives them certain advantages
in structures structurals applications
and that's some of the first
applications that they've had
but
probably the more interesting properties
are going to be how they affect uh the
flow of electrons their electronic
properties um and the
or
uh more recently we've been thinking
about how artificial quasi-crystal
structures that we could make in
essentially what we call electron
lithography machines which is like a
very high-end
3d printer how we could make 3d printed
patterns uh within a quasi-crystal
pattern
would have a unique effect on the flow
of light through them so that they would
effectively act like
super uh semiconductors for light
so we know in electronics semiconductors
are extremely important
uh in transistors and essentially all of
integrated circuit
technology and all the technology that
underlies our cell phones and our
computers and our communication devices
is based on electronics and in
particular the role of silicon and
germanium and other semiconductors in
being able to
modify
trap
change and alter the flow of electrons
is a crucial to that technology
but our one of the goals uh
in the future is to develop even faster
devices and faster than electrons
through materials is light and so there
is this vision that has been pursued for
the last few decades of replacing
electronics with photonics that is to
say light circuits rather than
electronic circuits
so for example the first thing you're
going to need is something that's
analogous to a wire in which the light
can simply flow well we know what those
are those are fiber optic cables and we
know that they exist and they they're
already being used quite a bit in in um
in our everyday lives for example in our
in bringing images and television to our
to our homes
um now the next thing you're going to
want beyond a wire is to create
something it's analogous to silicon a
semiconductor for light something that
plays the same rule of light for light
that
that
silicon does for electrons and it turns
out that
a quasi crystal
structure is advantageous for control
for acting like a semiconductor for
light it has
just like a semiconductor has something
called a band gap a perfect
semiconductor has a band gap a range of
energies which are forbidden to flow
through the material
if it's perfect it's the same is true
for the quasi-crystal and then
just like we dope our semiconductors and
produce defects in them intentionally in
order to be able to control and
manipulate the flow of electrons
something analogous exists for light in
quasi crystals but quasi crystals have
the advantage of crystals in that they
can be made uh much more spherical than
crystals can which means that the flow
of light is the same no matter how it
comes in and out of the quasi crystal
nearly so whereas for a crystal it's
very delicate you have to align the
light
if you were going to try to make a
photonic crystal you'd have to align the
light coming in and out very carefully
if you're trying to make a photonic
quasi crystal such a such careful
alignment is not needed and so that's
opened the way for
a new technology that we're pursuing
which is to use these quasi-crystal
patterns uh as a template for making
light semiconductors and it's also led
to other new forms of matter if you like
hypothetical forms of matter that we're
also pursuing which are neither crystal
nor quasi-crystal but yet something
different again
that we call a hyper uniform disordered
solid and they also have you know
interesting properties that are
different than either quasi crystals or
crystals and they too just like crystals
quasi crystals come in a whole zoo of
possible symmetries
um
these other solids contain
or have a whole zoology of different
possible properties as well so
what i really love about this subject is
you begin with something in your head a
mathematical pattern something
geometrical you can turn it into
something real and once you can show you
can make it something real it can become
a new material with sweet with the age
of 3d printing or and also being able to
control atoms at the atomic scale and
how they're arranged we can actually
make those materials rather than wait
for some chemists to figure out how to
do it and then you can it can next be it
some practical device so i find that
just just as exciting a discovery for
sciences other things that i do
uh just to find something that you know
came out of your head you know might
have some application or some very
unusual physical properties that we
thought were impossible before
yeah that's phenomenal yeah as uh as a
layer of instant gratification that you
can't be said of cosmology you know
yeah usually
instantaneous gratification or near
instantaneous usually almost eternal
um well paul it's been uh
just fantastic talking to you as always
and the book i want to remind people is
called the second kind of impossible
which will be out by the time this
podcast is posted it's the extraordinary
quest for a new form of matter
written by professor paul steinhardt
albert einstein professor in science at
princeton university published by simon
schuster
and i just want to
express my gratitude for you being on
the podcast and my expectation
that the
in the future harrison ford will be
known as the paul steinhardt of
archaeology rather than the indiana
jones of uh physics so paul steinhardt
uh thank you so much as always for uh
your graciousness and uh and very
stimulating conversation well thanks
brian thanks very much for having me on
the podcast